we got good news from ctv alberta
ditches proof of vaccine program at
midnight masking for students on monday
this story february 8th 7 27 pm eastern
time this is happening right now
alberta's highly controversial proof of
vaccination system expires as the clock
strikes midnight wednesday premier jason
kennedy announced tuesday amid
accusations that he was playing politics
with public health measures rules that
require students to wear masks in
alberta schools will end on monday and
children under 12 won't have to wear
masks anywhere starting then credit goes
to the truckers i don't care what they
say i don't care about the lies they
were never going to give up power now
we're hearing even in the u.s democrats
are likely to give up on the mandates
and what are they saying oh but the the
science has changed no no a bunch of
truckers crippled the capital of canada
and they all saw that happen they all
saw how powerless they were they all
heard that truckers were planning on
doing it here in the u.s they all saw
the polling and they said
we should back down on this one
science changed its mind this is uh
that's what happened here the honks
relationship science has changed
the science didn't change right you know
the the only respect in which you can
make that argument in good faith is
saying that the omicron is a lot less
virulent than and you know and and also
uh
morbid i guess would be the right word
than it was you know the og virus that
was coming out in like march 2020 or
whatever like that that's a valid
argument right the way you the way the
proper public health response to omicron
is very different i think than the
proper public health response to the
original virus and they it was so
unknown in the beginning that they over
not over they they reacted very
extremely because which is also rational
understandable precautionary and because
like you were saying it's hard to undo a
process once it's going yes it was kind
of now you see like stores that are
selling masks and stuff well and also
all of the decision making power was in
the hands of people who wouldn't pay a
price for overreacting and so you were
going to get an overreaction it's also
where polling was i mean if you look at
the polling is flipped right if you
actually look if you remember looking at
those polls in like march april 2020
they were like 80 20 in favor of severe
restrictions yeah and that's flipped
completely right it's now 20 80 20 the
other one yeah let me read this portion
of the ctv news article they say the
premier kenny recently said that a plan
to remove restrictions would likely come
by the end of march five days later he
changed the timeline when he said he
hoped to relax measures this month
last thursday a united conservative
party statement said the premier will
begin lifting restrictions within days
now what could have happened that would
make him just abruptly change his mind
and move the timeline by almost two
months could it be ottawa was shut down
and they were helpless
the political power we've discovered
here means that leftists are going to
try to infiltrate trucking you're going
to start seeing you're going to start
seeing psas about how they are they're
you know trucking is not a safe space
and we need like diversity and inclusion
training within it it won't work because
trucking is you by yourself and you're
rigged well the future of truth i'm
telling you they're going to do this
it's going to get automated they can't
they can't leave anything that has any
value or power they're going to automate
it and then they're going to try and
control the trucks i think that's also a
possibility that's what they're going to
do they're going to be like hey ottawa
you don't want to take the master the
food's not coming to your area because
we control all the shipping but think
about how awesome that will be then
yours is much funnier it's 20 years and
then all of a sudden one day
all automatic vehicles trucks and cars
gridlock dc and then they're like how is
this happening and then it's like no
it's like jeff bezos who bought the
companies holds the phone and he's like
no dude no it's it's it's it's some like
butt dialed 13 year old
it's some 13 year old who made a bunch
of money off of that era's version of
bitcoin and he's just purchased up all
the trucks
you buy the company that controls them
right so when they automate trucks it's
going to be a trucking company with no
drivers who just owns a fleet of trucks
that is terrifying and then it's going
to be one ceo being like
i can't believe they would pass this law
restricting my business beep and then
all the trucks i guess the issue i don't
think we can get self-driving trucks i
just realized that you know because you
know what's going to happen if ever but
anybody ever tries to do self-driving
trucks
this yeah the trucker convoy yeah oh
right
they've landed on a protest that they
found out really works quite well that's
true and so you know i don't just
repurpose it i wouldn't support that
protest i think automation's inevitable
it's kind of like the horse the
horseback riders protesting the car yeah
i don't think i don't think you get it
it doesn't matter if you support it
they're going to win they're going to
win
the thing about
you know bezos or any one billionaire
owning all the trucks is that the reason
they would never be able to do this
because if they did press the button
have all the trucks gridlock dc they'd
be arrested in two seconds they'd have
agents at their house they'd grab the
phone they'd change it they'd control it
but the other scenario is in 30 or 40
years
the trucks all of a sudden one day
gridlock dc and there's the you know
bezos runs out he's like it's not me i
don't have control of this and then
there's there's the real scenario in the
function here the real scenario is
china or some nefarious actor takes
control of an artificial intelligence a
rogue artificial intelligence literally
talking about our political rivals oh
hacking ourselves like you're trying to
score
you're talking about he's like babies
the other possibility i thought is
obvious
into optimus prime won't nuke everything
that's far too simple okay
what i was trying to say is one of our
rivals our adversaries across the globe
uses and hacks our infrastructure to
take control of it and gridlock our
system because you know china can't gain
mind control powers over over truckers
but they can
create a worm that infects all the
trucks and then allows them to control
it
but sure ian perhaps the trucks become
sentient also
i don't know that i would say china
can't start hacking people's brains it
depends on how popular metaverse becomes
yeah i mean but that's that i mean i
don't know how far off we are until the
brain implants and neural nets but uh
but being more facetious it's just
revenge for the opium wars exactly like
what's more dangerous a neural netted
human in in the driver's seat or an
automated truck
i i mean at least if there's just an
automated truck you haven't messed with
anyone's brain yeah they don't swing
around and stuff i don't know if we'll
ever reach the point where we have
artificial intelligence vehicles that
become sentient but uh it would be
interesting to see the million truck
march where all the trucks pull up and
they start spamming text messages and
there's a website that they've
artificially created that says like we
demand civil rights we can you know we
deserve access to resources and wages of
our choosing better fuel yeah also like
i'm sure i'm all electric i i'm sure at
some point there would be some kind of
government override within the system
too you know it's not just about
arresting the person i'm sure our
intelligence agencies can hack into it
there's a government override right now
it's called bullets yeah well yes
exactly but bullets don't hurt robots
tim
they do but it's it's really hard you
start the robot you shoot a robot truck
to death
yeah you shoot all of them bloods ties
that laser my point is if it ever came
to the point where the robots the
vehicles became sentient and were
explaining themselves and saying like i
am alive how did we get here because of
ian yeah and if if the cars were like i
am alive i feel and the government was
like we're going to delete your brain
like that would just be like the
government goes we're going to vaccinate
you that's like lobotomizing yeah so you
can't although there'd be a lot of
people saying they're just machines
they're not alive and then it's all it's
like star trek episode the make of a man
or whatever it's called with data and
they're trying to figure out if he's
alive or whatever um anyway back to a
more serious note the truckers are
winning i don't think we're gonna have
to worry about optimus prime taking over
dc or anything like that
but the truckers have been uh um
effective
i feel like the spirit of optimism lives
in canada right now man that i i got
goosebumps yesterday i was watching this
video of this guy in canada and i didn't
get the name of the guy but epic on the
loudspeaker like on his megaphone
telling him about freedom and it's like
for the first time in his life he's
proud to be a canadian and if you wanna
freedom scream it freedom and the crowd
goes what like they're ready for a
revolution of their government to
transition in some sort of democratic
republic
because they're not something that's not
the current democracy it's right it's
not structurally set up for it yet but i
think we can help them i mean the
americans alberta right we should we
should we should invade and liberate
canada they'll welcome us as liberators
exactly
regime change
it happens from the inside i'm just here
to
help make it peaceful didn't someone
tweet seriously recently that like we
would end up invading canada who was
that
uh what yeah i saw that i yeah i forget
who put i think it was i was just
federalist guys i was just kidding
right well we've invented canada before
it's true we have seven 1812. yeah we
tried taking montreal and then we left
i love this because if you actually read
it it's like one of those things that
kind of gloss over in high school or
elementary school history it's like oh
yeah we had the war of 1812 and we had a
peace treaty and that was great only
after the english kicked our ass they
burned the white house to the ground
that's right
we learned about that as if it was like
some rogue attack and not like them
completely demolishing that yeah we
almost had montreal
survived is because napoleon started
running wild all over europe and england
was like okay this is annoying you're
right do you think so they were gonna
take it back the country is that the
plan i'm not sure maybe just impose some
really brutal piece on us that was like
you know we can continue to seize your
ships and impress yourself yeah there's
still sailors literally just taking
sailors like actually you're ours now
yeah yeah yeah but napoleon
saved our napoleon yeah running wild all
over europe saved the great one of the
most dangerous empire villainous
you know mental in the history of
humanity the help to create american
democracy sold us the louisiana purchase
too which is so napoleon is is in
responsible multiple ways for the health
of so as an american you should actually
like the dude he's a big fan of american
democracy i know but it's just what
happened to him
he invaded russia yeah in the winter
funny are we trying to do something like
that soon where is he now
it's kind of crazy
it's crazy because like i was reading
that he was advised not to do it
you know and he was like i can do it
and he's just like it's wiped out it's
like don't invade russia in the winter
just like hold the line chill out yeah
they they all came to the defense at
that point literally every basically all
of continental europe at that point was
either directly run by part of france or
run by a vassal bro you got a grind
though you got to hit that grind he
wanted more he's too empty it was kind
of a situation where i think the british
the dutch i think was the dutch the
russians pretty much everyone in the
world was against him um and they would
have invaded and taken it back i think
if he didn't keep attacking it was like
well it was the english had england had
this nasty naval blockade on them right
and and also was just imposing like if
you trade with us you can't trade with
the french or something and basically i
mean it also i think that was the big
onus where it's like napoleon was trying
to bully everybody else into trading
with him and not trading with the
british and
you know that that ultimately was why he
kept expanding expanding to bring more
and more people under his control these
crazy europeans always fighting each
other it's true more and more bloody and
ridiculous wars happening in europe
what's going on with that those
europeans man yeah man i don't know it's
a good idea each other fighting each
other right now with ukraine and russia
it's probably they're having trouble
delivering resources it's probably i
think it's um it's a very high
population density and then border
proximity so that just that pressure
leads to
fierce you know competition not very no
good natural borders either that just
like stop invasions right and i mean
except for switzerland right yeah sure
switzerland but i mean you know if you
think about the united states you know
we're friendly country in the north one
country in the south and then you know
two oceans between any great powers
we got those two mountain ranges we
straight up just you know conquered this
this land east to west so exactly right
but there was no i mean there was no
centralized sovereign entity that was
existing the sioux was powerful but they
didn't have weapons not really and i
think
the smallpox were gnarly you ever want
to you know overcome that sort of weird
myth about the the sort of absolutely
innocent indian just read about the
comanches i mean or the aspects yeah the
aztecs right you know there there's look
guys i don't i think i think humans are
are brutal
brutal people in general regardless of
their culture whatever there's just like
drink blood for a living oh yeah cortez
was the good eat meat basically for a
living and there's blood in it cortisone
i wouldn't i don't know if i would say
that i would certainly just say like
history is bloody i think
people do bad things man there was well
i mean there was like the well i don't
want to go to yeah
it's not just it's not to say that there
were no yeah let's say the horrors of
war do anything evil but the empire they
defeated was horrific like we can
solidly say that the us were the good
guys in world war ii even though we did
do some horrific stuff like it was
absolutely wrong for us to nuke
hiroshima nagasaki fire bombing but i
would still say that i side with the us
over any other country in that conflict
so it's true
events too thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast if
you want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00 pm and don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and if you want more unfiltered and
uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time
you